uh
hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel did you like that did you
enjoy that was that was that good
i'm still learning adobe after effects
but if that was good give this video a
thumbs up i'm still trying to figure
things out but uh that was a pretty
helpful template and a lot of tutorials
went into that so today is my 18th
birthday
what does that mean to you what are you
gonna get out of that why'd i even tell
you that well actually in order to
enable subscribers on the new facebook
you have to be 18 years old and so i
just enabled subscribers so if you want
to subscribe to me on facebook i'm
moving to that instead of my page so
i'll have that link down below so you
can subscribe not add me as a friend but
subscribe so that you can see that kind
of stuff so i have a lot of reviews kind
of planned and coming up for you guys
that i'm still trying to to film and
edit and get out and i'm trying to make
this weekend awesome because it's my
birthday weekend and also i want to get
a lot of videos done so i can make them
and put them out this week i also plan
on making more youtube tips videos and
episodes of that you can see the
playlist in the link down below and you
can see the episodes i've already done
but if you guys have any more
suggestions for youtube tips episodes
you can leave them in a comment down
below and i know that there's going to
be one really special episode of youtube
tips coming up that's actually going to
feature a lot of you guys i've mentioned
this before so uh stay tuned for that
and make sure you stay subscribed if you
want to be a part of that anyway i'm
probably not alone in the geeks that are
just kind of sitting around putting
together our tech holiday wish lists and
what we want to give to our family and
hopefully that's not just tech support
uh but i realize this hasn't turned into
much of a video but there is a video
coming tomorrow on sunday so make sure
you are ready for that and uh
well yeah that's basically it also it's
going to be a giveaway video for the
holidays so i've already i've already
contacted the winner of the m50s
headphones uh if it happens to double
800 likes i'll probably give away
another pair i i don't know uh but yeah
this has been a quick little mkbhd
update video if you have any other
questions besides your youtube tips you
can also leave those in comments i do
answer all comments uh and uh yeah so
i'll talk to you later
peace
you